I've never thought about trying
cheerleading at all but you know I had a
free night
[Music]
I'm pretty excited about being on an
all-male squad I'm nervous about the
live performance that we're gonna have
to do I falter under pressure
the only other cheerleading experience
I've had was watching bring it on bring
it on bring it on ah yeah bring it on
right as a kid when I would go to
sporting events I would always look at
the cheerleaders I would wish maybe that
I was a cheerleader any other kind of
male sport has this like really like
dominant aggressive thing to it where I
think cheerleading is presented a little
bit more as graceful so I think girls
thrive in that and guys kind of step
away from that I think it's definitely
going to be hard for me to tap into
being what a cheerleader is I think if
you're a male cheerleader that doesn't
make you any less of a man
cheerleading goes against my own
personal idea of what a man is which
again I think speaks more about me than
anything else
but maybe I'll learn something new today
cheer LA is an all adult non profit team
dedicated to raising funds for HIV and
AIDS awareness charities we are part of
a large organization known as the pride
cheer Association that aims to raise
funds for local charities through our
cheer for life program one of the things
that I absolutely love about
cheerleading is the athleticism of it
the thrill of being physically active
and cheering and making people happy and
smile you can't beat that feeling she
only takes a lot of strain but it's
generally not just one person holding a
stunt so you really get to rely on each
other learn each other's strengths and
weaknesses and together we can do these
amazing stunts that you know we can
never fathom to doing around it's been a
great way to make lifelong friendships
because there's no stronger bond than
that you're me and if it's something
that you truly want to do never ever
ever give up and you're never too old to
do it 51 years old still doing it what
do you guys think it I think we got this
so the basics of stunts there's a couple
different positions that goes through so
there's the back spot which is the glue
of the stunt but the most responsible
job is making sure whoever's on top is
always
if you get hit it don't matter you catch
it no matter what there's also two bases
provide most power in the foundation fan
there's lastly that's the top for the
Flyers person going on top it puts their
life in these people's hands usually
based on body line and strength they got
you laundry good you go for it they got
you we don't got you the pedagogy and
we're going to teach you a dance today
hop one and two and three hold for your
right wrist over your left one twenty
they're gonna regress one two down drive
Oh down drive and settle that was really
that this is one hold two and two down
up one swing no they're gonna all right
good let's try from beginning real quick
from the top alright guys so that's the
dance so you're on your own
alright so we're at our first team
practice here I try to practice and
count off with these guys we struggled
when it came to the lifts we got a lot
of work to put in if we're gonna nail
this for the performance so Carl and I
just worked on the new cheer that we
have and we're kind of putting a mix of
what the cheer la taught us and what
bring it on taught us only we can pull
this off and you guys cheer that's been
a long day it's hard to find the
motivation to cheer so we've only had
one practice and we skipped like four or
five days and this is our second
practice so hopefully we remember stuff
yeah what comes after this Oh
it's one and done and then we're ready
you're ready flag in the back we're
really not done oh so the performance is
tomorrow and we just did a rehearsal a
pre performance if you will and I think
it went pretty good yeah some hiccups
but I feel like from now until the
performance we'll get it right yeah you
totally improved but if any of us messed
up it's gonna be pretty obvious so we
all individually have to bring it and
bring it on all right boys nothing hits
the floor was sticky
I said whoa it's changing it much people
eater healing I hit my head B u ZZ
buddies game yeah Ryan yeah I'm still
Edgar
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
I mean we nailed it about the fast and
the sexy when you're younger like
cheerleading and peppy nice sounds a
little corny but as an adult like being
positive is a good thing I didn't think
that I have to like turn down my
masculinity or anything like that for
this like when it came time to shake the
booty I was like you almost like the
booty on beat I think that doing here
definitely didn't decrease or increase
my masculinity I think it may be more
self-aware ever since high school it was
difficult for me to perform in front of
people I don't think it hurts my
masculinity I think it just makes it
more solidified I really do think that
more men should try cheerleading I feel
stronger because of of working with
these guys I think if you want to like
prove how agile you are how strong you
are how quick you are how competitive
you can be vocal cheerleader
[Music]
Wow